hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today our subject in question
is of course judeskaisen and more
specifically why this beautiful little
series is an evolution
on the entire shonen formula big words
there
yes i know and whilst this may initially
seem like the raving praise of a mad
fanboy i am here to assure you that this
is absolutely not hyperbole or as i said
for the first 18 or so years of my life
hyper bowl but i think where this
discussion may become immediately
obnoxious is when people try to sell
jujutsu kaisen as like this fresh
original experience because
it's not jujitsukai's scent on paper
falls into and actively wields a lot and
i mean a lot of classic shonen tropes
however where this series becomes an
evolution on the genre is more to do
with how it uses those classic elements
as well as the few key tropes that it
actively chooses to emit it's those
clever and select decisions that make
judas kaiser not necessarily
revolutionary but certainly
evolutionary and we're going to begin
this exploration with a quick round of
curse or purse a very simple minigame
the rules of which are as follows
gugisaki has recently been shopping and
has bought a lovely purse however there
is a chance that this purse is in fact
a curse a cursed purse if you will but
it's going to be your job to guess which
it is and should you guess incorrectly
then your binding vowel punishment will
be to subscribe to the new world review
which will also result in consistent
injections of cursed content
administered straight into your youtube
feed and if you are correct then you
will have the privilege of carrying the
rest
of kugasaki shopping hooray so which
will it be
purse or curse purse make your choice
now and we shall reveal the answer in
three two one and bam it's a regular old
purse so if you were paranoid enough to
say curse then you know a thing to do
and please do say hi in the comments
below if you are a new member of this
here
channel welcome so gege akitami author
of jujutsukai sen and self-depicted
one-eyed cat despite this depiction
akatami is actually a very empathetic
and understandable figure to me because
we're roughly the same age and we fell
in love with the world of anime and
manga during the same sort of era by
which i mean the age of what is called
the big
three being the titles of one piece
naruto and bleach which basically
dominated everything shonen and like
most authors akatami took a particular
liking to one of those three being
bleach
and the work of tita kubo in general in
addition to that akatami also had a lot
of love for the work of yoshihiro
tagashi
specifically citing you haksho and
hunter hunter which immediately gives us
a great idea of the subgenre that
jujutsu kaisen is really pushing forward
which is the realm of dark shonen
the sort of series that either deal with
intense subject matter more than your
feel good happy shonen series and other
examples of dark shonen include classics
like death note d
grey man or even attack on titan stuff
that really pushes the boundaries of
what can be done in terms of story
themes and artwork without turning into
a full-blown saint in series like
berserk
ants or villain saga although one can
argue that at times that line is
definitely
definitely crossed not quite today
though because jujutsu kaisen is quite
firmly ashonin and you can tell because
it adopts
many many key tropes whether that be the
high school setting the power of
friendship vibes all sorts of classic
protagonist parental issues and lately
in the manga we're even about to see the
series take on its own sort of
tournament arc and saying all of those
things one after the other in a listy
sort of format does sound rather cringey
and annoying because we know the
standard way in which all of those ideas
tend to play out but the brilliance
fakatami's work is how these tropes are
applied
so for example the high school setting
it plays almost no role in the events of
the actual manga
yes yuji and friends of yuji technically
study at a place called jiuutsuhai but
they've never been shown having any
classes or doing any typical high school
activities the closest we've come i
suppose would be the kyoto goodwill
event but other than that the fact that
they're high school students
is almost completely irrelevant really
studying at jujutsu high is more akin to
being a new employee at a company our
students are thrust straight into work
and don't have to deal with painful
complications of the high school setting
similarly judas kaisen is not immune
from the old power of friendship trope
you know the whole we're stronger
together and we can overcome all of the
anything sort of vibe however it is
utilized very differently akatami
actually goes to some pretty great
lengths to subvert the trope by putting
a huge emphasis on the fact that jude's
sorcerers are quintessentially lonely
existences and destined to die alone at
the same time however our main character
is trying to halt that trend by making
sure that he dies surrounded by others
so the power of friendship is much more
naturally applied and definitely not
anywhere near as in your face as like a
classic protagonist makes speech about
not being alone style
sort of thing and with yuji as well as
everyone else
the idea is very internalized ah and
speaking of internal
a big big trope that jutsukai sin taps
into is that of the inner demon
like a literal inner demon and this is
where yuji rips are paid straight out of
the book of ichigo but it's obviously
not an exclusive feature to bleach but i
feel like jujutsu kaisen is the first
series to really examine the oh damn
aspect of the inner demon trope like
there is no trusting sukuna whatsoever
there is no working with sukuna and he
may very well be the primary antagonist
of the entire series so the one thing i
really hope never happens is yuji and
sukun are having this moment of like a
permanent teamer in the exact same way
that does tend to happen with every
other inner demon in churning because
there is no redemption for tsukuna he's
done something some seriously messed up
stuff and there is very very good reason
why many people would rather have yuji
executed right here and now but further
bleach inspiration can also be seen with
the concept of domains which certainly
do have a bank is quality to them just
with a lot more rules and in many ways
they're a lot more overpowered
speaking of rules this is something that
jujutsu kaisen absolutely excels at it
sets rules for its world and its power
system and
then it does something even better which
is that it abides by those rules and i
know that sounds really simple
but it's it's really not and this starts
out at a very basic level by explaining
how to conjure cursed energy but it ends
up evolving into these wildly complex
situations featuring a litany of cursed
mechanics at play simultaneously as well
as the ever expanding domains and domain
countermeasures so i've made this
comparison before but the curse system
is extraordinarily evocative of the nen
system of hunter hunter but the whole
manifestation of x energy being
channeled into y
ability although i would say that
akutami has set fast stricter
limitations and togashi did but the
result is still
extremely effective absolutely anything
akatami wants to happen
can happen with a satisfactory
explanation and if you keep looking it
does fulfill other shonen tropes like
the absentee parents the glorious mascot
character that is panda
ah such a good character and so on and
so forth but equally as important is
what jujutsu kaisen chooses to emit
there are particular shonen features and
devices that akutami goes to great
lengths not to include in the series
one of which is fan service i think one
of the most wild thoughts i've ever had
about jiu jitsu kaisen was when i
finished my read-through and i realized
that i'd never seen kugisaki in a bikini
or her underwear
or in the shower or like anything
however many ways authors find to really
showcase the
the female form as well as the male form
actually but the same goes for other
female characters as well mai
maki miwa in fact i think the closest we
may have come to
fanservice is yugi's poster of jennifer
lawrence and maymay
sort of i mean she has this very
provocative volume cover but even with
her seductress style character she still
spends most of her time
very very dressed and i really can't
think of a single instance where we've
even come close to objectifying a female
character even takura whose role as an
idol is essentially to be objectified
and to me it just goes to prove
something that i've thought for a very
very long time which is that fan service
really doesn't
add much if any value to a series if
anything it just takes that valuable
time away from story and getting to know
these characters
similarly in jujutsu kaisen there is
next to no element of comical romance by
which i mean stuff like
say sanji from one piece fawning over
every woman in existence or even the
other way around like noel in black
clover being all
sunderer with astor and as a result the
characters just feel a lot more
like real and it's easier to be immersed
in the manga because nobody does
like cinderella yandere thing in real
life and nobody does it in shoot sky
sense so that immediately puts it one
step closer to reality than most shown
in series
and another thing that akhitami
generally leaves by the wayside is the
idea of big dreams this one gets talked
about
a lot you know luffy wants to become the
pirate king
astor wants to become the wizard king
and naruto wants to become what is
essentially the ninja king
ash wants to be the very best like no
one ever was as does hinata just with
volleyball instead
of legally sanctioned animal fights
whereas yuji
he he just wants to do a good thing for
the world and then die with some close
friends by his side fushiguru is driven
by an ideology the good people deserve a
chance to be saved and the most
simplistic of all is gugisaki whose
entire life to this point has been
guided by the desire to just meet her
old friend again that and eat nice
things in the city food is also
important they're almost stunningly
mundane goals for a trio of protagonists
and usually i would argue that this is a
bad detractive feature i personally do
believe that shonen tends to work best
when our main characters have grand
ambition
something that we can really get on
board with and experience their drive to
achieve it but then again when you
consider the world of jujitsu kaisen
these characters do have some pretty
grand goals take yuji he might not want
to become the cursed
king or whatever but his whole idea of
not dying alone is apparently one of the
most ridiculously difficult things to
achieve in this particular world and
that's because for a story about magical
curse powers it's pretty highly grounded
in reality
our characters for the most part have
very basic human desires that we can
identify with and because it is so hard
to achieve those desires it's almost the
equivalent of saying something like yeah
i am going to become the cursed king
because that's just how dystopic this
world is that even the very basics are a
far away dream
and another important feature that
akatami purposely neglects is the
concept of the status quo jujutsukai sen
has never and will
never feature a status quo a state where
things begin and eventually return
back to after a big event and you see
this all too often in many other major
shonen series where after some sort of
gigantic climactic arc perhaps even saga
everything just ends up being okay life
goes back to the way it was
and there are no enduring consequences
whereas jujitsukai sen is constantly in
a state of flux
events happen things change more events
happen and then more things
change consequences are an essential
element of the series
it feels very very natural less like
we're coming to the end of a written and
structured story arc and more like we're
just watching the world move forward on
its own
which is a thing that the world does we
can never go back to a certain point in
history after any particular global
event in the real world things just keep
changing
and evolving and i feel like jujutsu
kaisen really reflects that feeling and
i also appreciate that
judas kaisen rarely has what i would
call a correct answer
every action even those taken by our
protagonist is very much in question
from a moral perspective one of my
favorite examples of this would be from
the death painting aqua afterwards yuji
and kugisaki have to find their own ways
to contend with what they've just done
and this goes on to haunt yuji in
particular for a fair while as do most
of his actions really and even when our
characters are very much doing the right
thing in a particular circumstance the
way in which they perform those actions
can also leave
questions during extreme situations our
supposed good guys can really go down
quite a dark path with fushigura and
kogisaki in particular
being known for concerning maniacal
facial expressions
almost as if to state that they are
enjoying the sick battle far more than
anyone should
if indeed they should be enjoying it at
all and when these features are put
together it also leads to the omission
of another trope being sweet victory the
idea that yeah we beat the bad guy and
now we all get to celebrate and stuff
judit skysen does not operate like that
oftentimes even when we do achieve
victory it comes at a great cost
and there are several occasions where
victory essentially feels like the
equivalent of a loss
meanwhile all of the above and more is
the combined reason for why jujitsu
kaisen receives the insane praise it
does it's not because it necessarily
presents us with anything new
most of its key elements can be found on
mass in any battle shown in series but
what i think it does go on to prove is
that tropes are not
a bad thing unless they're used by
not so great writers tropes can be used
well they can be used very well
and it also pays to be very conscious of
which ones to employ and which ones to
not touch with a 10 meter cursed
tool pole that is jude skysen an
evolution of the shonen formula focusing
on what classic elements to work with
and innovative ways of using them as
well as identifying what classic
elements are probably a bit past their
expiration date
and may need to be retired from the
genre but now that you've watched this
video go
and watch more videos more of my videos
to be precise because there are things
things you will like
like this video so i look forward to
seeing you there